one of the most recognized ships in the
US Navy is ready for service again after
a massive overhaul the USS Abraham
Lincoln just finished a four-year four
billion dollar makeover in southeastern
Virginia Jan Crawford spoke with the
shipbuilders who had a role in this
project she's at a Naval Station she's
at a Naval Station in Norfolk with a
special tour of the aircraft carrier Jan
good morning well good morning so these
ships are really like the emergency
response team for the world I mean
whenever there's a major conflict or
humanitarian crisis the carriers are
there no other country has anything like
America's fleet which means no other
country has the kind of shipbuilders who
build and keep these ships running the
90,000 ton USS Abraham Lincoln is one of
the largest warships in the world with
the proud history when the u.s. prepared
to take on Saddam Hussein in 1991 the
newly built USS Lincoln patrolled the
Persian Gulf during the 2003 invasion of
Iraq the ship launched over a hundred
missions a day and served as a site of
one of president george w bush's most
famous announcements and when an
historic tsunami killed hundreds of
thousands in southeast asia the lincoln
rushed to the region to provide relief
now nearly three decades after it first
departed newport news the lincoln is
heading out again for another 25 years
at sea better than ever after a
four-year upgrade and overhaul at the
Huntington Ingalls shipyard we're pretty
close to the trial now right Huntington
Ingalls CEO Mike Pettis gave us a tour
of the carrier just before it was turned
back over to the Navy right over here
are the catapults where the planes go
right off the bow of the ship during the
overhaul that catapult along with every
component aboard the Lincoln underwent
extensive renovation responsibilities
petter said he and his employees take
seriously what does that mean like to
work here on this aircraft carrier well
first of all it's a privilege a
privilege privilege the nation entrusts
us with creating these complex
platforms that are going to take really
the most valuable resource we have which
is our young sailors and take them into
harm's way often deployed for months at
a time more than 5,000 people can live
aboard the Lincoln when it's fully
staffed that's a city it is a city with
its own Airport it's got all the things
that you need to accommodate 5,000
people in a city between food sleeping
arrangements entertainment training
every single thing that has to happen to
support the mission of the ship and then
you're going to go and drive this city
around out there at sea in an
environment that's actually pretty harsh
at some point the quality of our work is
going to get tested and it can't fail it
won't fail the man steering this massive
construction project was u.s. Navy
captain Ron Ravello before it came here
to Newport News you looked at like maps
right absolutely
you were using maps and and one of the
things you've done the last four years
is now this will all be navigated with
electronics Ravello said he'd like to
remind his crew what they're working
towards conceivably one of their sons or
daughters will be a member of the last
crew of this ship you know 25 years from
now you know that's how much life we're
putting back into this another
generation it's another generation of
sailors maybe even two to help recruit
and train qualified shipbuilders
Huntington Ingalls relies on its
apprentice school with an admissions
process as competitive as the Ivy League
students get paid to take classes while
getting hands-on experience and working
full-time toward a college degree these
four graduates span generations each had
a hand in getting the USS Lincoln ready
for duty it's spruill has been a
pipefitter at Newport News for 39 years
and his son now also works in the
shipyard
spruill help build the Lincoln and plans
to retire once the overhaul is complete
what does that mean to you to have been
able to kind of see that through there's
just something about this stage when
you're ready to go to see that when you
go down that River and you know all
those hours were put in and now you go
down on sea trials just a pride
what you do thirty-three-year-old
ramírez crumbly is an electrical Foreman
do you think that you feel that pride -
yes ma'am
I mean I didn't get it at first when I
first got here I mean I just started was
a job and then to actually complete a
carrier and to actually see it go out to
see I mean it's just outstanding and it
just makes you feel special as a person
that hey I was a part of that project
for medical and kristoff Lucas both
served aboard aircraft carriers in the
Navy it kind of makes you work a little
bit harder especially after knowing what
it's like to live on a ship all for
shipbuilders said working on equipment
that helps keep the country safe carries
with it a heightened sense of
responsibility in building ships with
the 50 year lifespan can quickly become
personal
my son is seven years old and he tells
me every day how he wants to be in the
military I mean in the Navy or something
like that I was 17 when I got in the
military and if he's if he follows in my
shoes he's gonna want to do the same
thing and if he's on a ship I want it to
be right because you could be working on
something now that he will be on
absolutely and that's that's something I
take very seriously now with the next
generation of carriers already being
built Huntington Ingalls industries
expected to be busy for decades to come
and to make sure that they have enough
shipbuilders to do the work CEO Mike
cutters actually donates his salary to
pay for preschool scholarships for the
children of his employees hoping they'll
follow their parents into the shipyard
Nora Oh Jan what a great story
you know aircraft carriers are the
largest projection of a nation's power
into other areas it may last 50 I mean
50 years think about that out to sea for
25 years and the sense of community
around the people took me the pride and
the confidence is Network struck me in
that story